you seem like a guy who's i don't know
relax
centered like you know who you are uh
i'm going to have
a lot of free time now for a while we're
going to start something else up but
i'm going to have some down time and i
honestly i'm not even kidding
i don't really know what to do with down
time yeah i get that sense from you yeah
really tell me yeah i do i mean i
remember doing your live show in
vancouver after and i remember being
with you backstage we were just like
what is happening right now
like why are you doing this i demand i
demanded that
that i had all the time to like take
some time off before we started the next
thing and i'm like no
yeah we're doing more shows all across
the country
i think theaters yeah i needed to be
medicated but it was still a lot of fun
no it was a pleasure to
play a part in your therapy
but uh yeah i think you do have time on
your hands i would suggest
uh this is gonna be hilariously on brand
try smoking a lot of weed for a long
time
i mean try it you seem like someone who
doesn't smoke a lot of weed to me
i don't smoke any weed and that's not a
judgment i i am
kind of uh uh i'm lucid
i enjoy my lucidity uh never a sentence
i've even
thought in my life
but it's true like i'm not i am not well
andy you you've known me a long time
i've
i it's not that i have any problem with
people uh smoking pot i think it's
actually
you know uh it seems to be a fine herb
uh
but i enjoy it ever a sign you didn't
smoke weed it's that you just called it
a fine
it's a fine herb as i'm told but the
couple of times i've tried it like it
didn't it
nothing really happened and well yeah
and then
i i think it metabolizes and becomes
more orange pompadour
but you but i know that you own a weed
company so you might
actually have you might be able to tell
me maybe i was smoking the wrong stuff
yeah you know i don't know i don't know
what would you you know me what would
you want me
smoking
okay
i swear to god this is how this is how
this is how lame i am for a second i
thought he brought a birthday candle
that is no birthday candy no don't smoke
that now this will be
or do this will be a great weird show
for all what is this
what is it real what is it really what
is weed i know it's
weeds i didn't think it was pencil
shaving but i'm curious like
are you you were as a professor of weed
telling me that this is the kind you
think i should use
i think you should take one hit of that
weed
one hit of that weed and i think you'll
have a really good time
okay yeah i don't have a light do you
have a light does anyone have a lighter
yeah
this is the kind of thing you do when
you know it's over for you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh what are they gonna do oh what are
they gonna do to me i'm so
nervous right now i know i'm
[Applause]
i seriously 120 people other ways either
way
i really don't know what to do
all right all right tell me and then
just get right in there huh okay yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right
i'll hold on to this right you better
hold on to that
when does this thing that's gonna happen
happen uh well we'll wait a few minutes
and see how you feel and then maybe you
have a little bit more if you're uh
still functional
i'm driving a school bus in an hour yeah
good
now people are going to be looking for
anything i do and be like
exactly like i'll do this and i'll be
like he's high yeah
i've been doing that for a long time
i was complimenting you backstage i'm so
happy with what just happened
[Applause]
i i'm actually i wasn't expecting any of
this i'm not because
i forgot i applied for a job at target
[Laughter]
i'm laughing way too long
wow yeah is it supposed to burn it kind
of burns it's very much supposed to burn
that's exactly
smoke inside your body
right cause i sucked it in right right
okay
all right i like how controlling i am
about it i'm
you know i mean i'm like a narc that
they
to prove that he was not a narc it's
true
took a shift some drugs yeah do you ever
get wet conan
that's what denzel asked in training
date yeah yeah
well when you have to explain a joke you
know
he's meaner cause he's hot that's what
happens to me
you